hello welcome it's Halloween again why
not again it's not it's not it's um it's
another Halloween celebration I gotta
get my mask
it's Halloween is that the ghost of my
dead parents my parents are dead so I'm
Batman he is I'm a cave literally just a
cave woman we had new costumes that we
got and um yeah he picked that one I
didn't pick it you cooked it you begged
it you paid I didn't order any whatever
so today with our pumpkins we're not
gonna be cutting them open we're gonna
be exploding them over we're gonna be
exploding them open by seeing how many
rubber bands it takes to blow off one of
these and then we have another notion
that you have to wait to see if don't
skip ahead once again if you skip ahead
in the video and see the surprise
[Music]
that'll happen he's Batman we're not
gonna time ourselves cuz we'll just
whoever gets it first right right feed
it down gee my nipples gonna pop out
every time I put her hand around it
that's okay it's added entertainment but
that's not the special surprise if you
fast-forward and saw that loser all
right I guess go I gotta I gotta like
get rid of this stem come on be a man
Batman wait we never drew faces what is
why I gotta stop jeez my guy's gonna be
screaming there we go good enough I feel
like mine has gotten skinnier I feel
like mine hasn't done jack yet oh did it
get you in another okay so ignore the
fact that it's completely different
looking than it was yesterday nothing's
changed
I mean you said yesterday you shut up
it's annoyed it's the same day it's the
same day at same time exactly my boobs
come out Batman just wanted to grab a
handful though for safety because our
fingers were torn to [ __ ] today we got
gloves now because we're smart yours is
probably gonna explode and kill me why
would it kill you cuz its murderous a
man doesn't kill nobody
no bad man would ever look up good
I've got cleavage Batman would never
never kill anybody with cleavage like
that ah damn my pumpkins being squeezed
by the Iron Fist of justice I've got a
Justice boner hello put a gun down max
forming in the bonded bag down whoo now
I'm getting scared it's gonna like load
at any second I was like oh he's never
gonna blow I think they got more brittle
I think the Joker's playing a joke on
this but I'm really glad my mouth wasn't
open
here's this
really skews exquisite who it is cui
holy [ __ ] okay really some faces oh boy
oh geez
I feel like it's all weapon soon I saw
one break hmm Yee I heard a noise oh my
god I heard a noise I hear it the time
bomb oh my god that's like a perfect
pumpkin ball
it was decapitated oh man I thought the
whole thing was Italian it was okay then
what's a call when they cut your head in
freakin half
oh that's justice delivered right there
woohoo grody oh no the poor guy he was
like a pumpkin like you go I go you go I
go ah [ __ ] wrong you know everything
oh oh there's definitely a crack right
there
Oh chica chica chica put you go on the
table she can shield us
chica no oh god oh god
[Music]
sheekha you're so brave Oh chica my gosh
did you see the fear in her eyes
yeah that's definitely bigger than this
one maybe that was pretty nice but
inefficient I'd say yeah it didn't
explode yeah and that's what we really
wanted so we have another way to make
the pumpkin blower that's it we're gonna
go get it
okay so our original plan was to then
cut these open put some dry ice in them
glue them back together and then blow
them up we looked it up and uh that
would qualify as a dry ice bomb and
those are illegal in the state of
California so we're not gonna do that
because we don't want to be arrested so
make sure and check no you know what
just just don't do that it's stupid
people get hurt all the time don't put
it in there we figured this would be
okay because it was just pumpkins but
just plain old don't do it so now that
that's all been done we've got a whole
assembly of pumpkin here - what was my
name wasn't I didn't even name mine on
for I kill name yours
you think you'd name something before it
dies horribly yeah like really horribly
though should be rock paper scissors for
the right - sledge first it only seems
appropriate I mean given the
circumstance let me put this all right
I'm ready all right
no yes you don't get to unleash your
inner cave woman first all right watch
out did I smash mine or so though
express yours you get first opportunity
I'm gonna smash yours that's oh no his
name is oh no his name is oh no my name
is fred durst fred durst yeah because
he's apparently
the person I stole this hair from Oh
twenty one pilots isn't the same fred
durst whatever here we go all right I
was oddly satisfying so I'm going for
Squidward
of what it was his name I forget doof
doof dudes do I think it's Squidward
more than I'm dupes gonna get it you
couldn't see at home uh not only did do
fit but everything it was a tanning on
well all right then you also
collaterally got uh Fred Durst here I
think that was the table dude his head
his head just came off oh geez
well can you put Fred Durst's head back
on please he's not done yet I feel like
and this isn't because you know I'm
trying to be malicious or anything I
feel like I don't want
you have to kill hmm okay but then bear
they like anyone should all right I
should be the one to bear that burden
yeah
I'm sorry little buddy you'll always be
my little busy up in heaven I'm worried
about this one all right so he needs to
stay on their floor the next 10 he just
wants to help
now it's sludge pumpkin Tim he'd become
stronger than we could have been going
for the one in front of oh geez okay
ha ha ha here we go you keep exploding
everything I'm like kind of doing it
generally gentle enough you just mister
boy everything you look at like my
goodness we're not reusing this table
there was a reason I asked you if it was
okay I I didn't figure you'd put huge
holes in it and if we're gonna go whole
hog I'm moving up better working in the
where Batman seeking justice are you
doing to kill my parents
[Music]
okay so that was the something to do
with pumpkin challenge hope you guys
enjoy that thanks so much Holly for
joining me
yeah thank you for asking it anymore
sweeties alright so thank you everybody
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
please let us know down in the comments
below and if you got other Halloween
themed
hmm one of these days you're gonna woo
with me so anyway thanks again everybody
for watching and as always we'll see you
in the next video bye bye we'll put them
back to you